gelten als die helden der pandemie
krankenschwestern und pfleger ärztinnen
und ärzte die helden behandelt fühlen
sich die meisten allerdings nicht die
zahlung des versprochenen pflege bonus
die wird ins neue jahr verschoben
schnell entschieden hat man dagegen die
impfpflicht für das personal von
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen um die
kliniken zu entlasten muss die vierte
welle gebrochen werden darüber und über
die gefahr von omikron beriet heute auch
der neue chor ohne expertenrat und die
gesundheitsminister die haben
entschieden dass die testpflicht nach
der blues der impfung entfallen soll
aber was hilft wirklich schnell den
operationen werden verschoben patienten
verlegt fachkräfte fehlen viel
versprochen wenig gehalten pflegekräfte
am limit unser thema in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich dafür meine
gäste vorstellen bei uns ist ja in wisla
sie ist vorsitzender der partei die
linke herzlich willkommen und herzlich
willkommen nicole best ich von der fdp
sie ist die pflegepolitische sprecherin
der bundestagsfraktion
und zugeschaltet ist uns nina bühler sie
ist krankenpflegerin und bekannt
geworden durch ihr buch euren applaus
den könnt ihr euch sonst wohin stecken
pflegenotstand materialmangel zeitnot
was alles in unserem gesundheitssystem
schief läuft zurzeit ist den eltern zeit
und herzlich willkommen professor doktor
uwe jansons er ist chefarzt am st
antonius hospital in eschweiler und
vorsitzender der deutschen vereinigung
für intensiv und notfallmedizin
schönen guten abend herr professor jan
sind nach einem langen arbeitstag für
sie schon wie sieht er aus dieser alltag
im moment für ihre pflegekräfte und ihre
ärztin und ärzte
ja es ist ein dauerläufer dauer marathon
von pedro ist wirklich jetzt seit 21
monaten 22 monaten befinden und es ist
wirklich kann ich ihnen leider wird
sagen nicht besser geworden und der tag
heute wenn ich jetzt so resümiere ist
eigentlich augenblick so ein bisschen
schlimmer geworden die mitarbeiten
pflegekräfte ärzte ärzte sind alle müde
sind zum teil auch genau weil dauernd
was neues kommt und der tages angefüllt
mit kuwait 1990 kommen morgens zur
arbeit um allen zu helfen aber wir
stoßen immer wieder an unsere grenzen
immer mehr an unsere grenzen und das
muss und das soll das muss ich dringend
in den nächsten kommenden jahren ändern
wir hoffen wirklich sehr dass sich jetzt
auch was in der politik tut das endlich
vor allen dingen für die pflegenden was
getan wird dass sich hier grundsätzlich
etwas ändert denn der tag wie heute wenn
ich ihn das schüttere das wollen sie
eigentlich gar nicht wissen erzählt es
uns trotzdem
ja ich kann ihnen sagen wir haben
mittlerweile
durch auch im westen ich bin ja hier im
westen der republik in der nähe von
aachen zunehme corona infektionszahlen
das merken wir sowohl auf der
intensivstation aber natürlich auf der
normalstation das wird dann der stelle
auch immer vergessen dass wir ganz viele
patientinnen mit 19 auf sogenannte mit
19 solider stationen haben und die
pflegekräfte sind doch auch seit 22
monaten damit beschäftigt sich
tagtäglich vor jedem zimmer ein zu
kleiner umzuziehen also wird eine enorme
belastung für die leute und jeden tag
kommen neue dazu es werden welche
verlegt auf der intensivstation starben
patientinnen mit und ohne kurven aber
vor allen dingen die mit 19 nach
wochenlanger therapie auch diese woche
haben uns wieder zwei patienten
verlassen und das stimmt die in
intervallen traurig dass belastet sie
sehr was man dagegen tun kann darüber
spricht man natürlich weiter in dieser
sendung frau böhmer sie haben natürlich
gehöre natürlich ganz viel auch von
ihren kolleginnen und kollegen und das
was sie am anfang auch der pandemie
erlebt haben hat sie ja dazu gebracht
dieses buch zu schreiben wo sie gesagt
haben dass applaus das ist nicht genug
was würde es was ist ihr eindruck was
ist im moment ganz hat er gesagt diese
22 monate lange zeit jetzt was ist im
moment wäre das wichtigste oder was ist
das was die pflegekräfte am meisten
umtreibt
also da muss sich herr doktor ganzen
zustimmen die rückmeldung habe ich auch
dass alle meine kollegen eigentlich
sozusagen die nase voll haben sie sind
sehr erschöpft und die belastung ist ja
nicht nur auf intensivstationen groß
sondern auch auf die normale station in
den reha einrichtungen in den ambulanten
pflegediensten auch in den altenheimen
überall merkt man die mehrbelastung und
ja corona hat auf jeden fall in anteil
daran aber es war ja auch schon vorher
das problem und wir brauchen auf jeden
fall mehr personal und wir brauchen eine
politik die jetzt endlich mal das
problem an der wurzel anpacken wo wäre
denn die wurzel ihrer meinung nach
also am besten wäre es tatsächlich das
ganze system zu reformieren
mann möchte uns ja wieder prämien
auszahlen die dänen sicherlich auch
viele dankend an aber ich glaube der
größte teil der möchte diese prämien
gehalten gar nicht sondern wir wollen
tatsächlich wirklich änderungen im
gesundheitssystem die auch nachhaltig
sind am besten mehr personal ich weiß
die feinen auch nicht von den bäumen
aber ja man muss an den
arbeitsbedingungen was ändern und die
tatsache dass dieser versprochene pflege
bonus in von insgesamt einer milliarde
euro jetzt erst mal eben nicht vor
weihnachten ausgezahlt sondern erst mal
wieder verschoben wird wie empfinden sie
das
ja also man begründet das ja glaube ich
so dass man in ruhe entscheiden will wer
diesen bonus bekommt da ist halt auch
wieder die frage genau wer bekommt den
bekommen die nur die intensivpflege
kräftig würde das den natürlich können
aber wie hat schon gesagt auch die
anderen kollegen haben diese
mehrbelastung auf den normalen station
in den altenpflegeheimen überall werben
meist wie erwähnt und ja dann habt ihr
glaube ich auch der arbeitgeberverband
pflege jetzt gesagt sie würden den bonus
gerne nur an geimpftes personal
auszahlen wo ich mich halt auf frage
warum nicht an alle dann auch dieser
kleine teil der ungeimpften die haben ja
genauso die letzten zwei jahre
sich ich sagte meinen anführungsstrichen
den arsch aufgerissen und haben
menschenleben gerettet und um diese
leben gekämpft und deswegen verstehe ich
nicht warum man da wieder so
unterschiede macht ok fragen wo jemand
direkt nach westen das hat natürlich zu
irritationen geführt man hat versprochen
einen pflege bonus und hat wir brauchen
mehr geld und jetzt sagt man er wisse
noch nicht genau wem also warum läuft es
nicht warum kann man den menschen die so
belastet sind nicht wirklich das geld
auszahlen was sie ihrer meinung nach ja
auch verdient haben das geld soll ja
ausgezahlt werden aber ich denke gerade
der beitrag von frau böhmer hat gezeigt
welche fragen noch offen sind und da
geht gründlichkeit vor schnelligkeit wir
müssen
die akteure bitten uns diejenigen zu
nennen die besonders belastet sind in
der pandemie und das sind eben nicht nur
die pflegenden auf den intensivstationen
sondern zum beispiel auch die
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
notaufnahmen durch die vielen
verlegungen von denen wir jetzt gehört
haben all das muss gründlich erfasst
werden und dann soll es
selbstverständlich schnell auch zur
auszahlung des pflege bonus kommen ich
möchte aber auch betonen dass das nur
ein kleiner aspekt ist eines ganzen
pakets das wir auch im rahmen des
koalitionsvertrags geschnürt haben wo
wir wirklich dann uns anstrengen und
maßnahmen ergreifen wollen um gerade die
personalsituation in der pflege
nachhaltig zu verbessern eine höhere
bezahlung ist natürlich auch eine
gewisse attraktivität und das ist ja
schon schwierig zu verstehen dass man
auf der einen seite schnell die
impfpflicht für das personal entscheidet
aber das andere da sagt man man man
braucht noch zeit verstehen sie da nicht
den unmut ich kann jeden unmut verstehen
und ich kann auch und da spreche ich
auch für die kolleginnen und kollegen
aus der arbeitsgruppe gesundheit und
pflege die den koalitionsvertrag
verhandelt haben wir können das alles
verstehen aber wir
müssen ich möchte jetzt auch um
verständnis bitten die der
gesundheitsausschuss wie alle anderen
ausschüsse auch wird sich morgen erst
konstituieren wir sind noch nicht
richtig angekommen ja aber die regierung
waren
aber jetzt nicht die
versäumnisse der vorangegangenen
regierungen dafür bitte ich auch
unverständlich frau wissler wie wichtig
ist es dass es mehr geld gibt die linke
hat glaube ich auch gefordert 500 euro
mehr grundgehalt also wie wichtig ist
dass und wie empfinden sie das das oder
was würden sie sagen der muss jetzt wie
dieses geld diese extra prämie bekommen
ja wir halten es für sinnvoll dass es
diese extra prämie gibt wären es ja auch
im deutschen bundestag in der letzten
woche beantragt weil ich auch in der tat
mir das verständnis fehlt warum man
jetzt das gesetzespaket auf den weg
gebracht hat genau dieses versprechen
daran nicht eingelöst hat und ich bin
nicht der meinung dass man das jetzt
ganz eng ziehen sollte sondern wir haben
ja gerade gehört alle beschäftigten in
den krankenhäusern in den
pflegeeinrichtungen sind hoch belastet
und deswegen als anerkennung für diese
arbeit hat er ist jetzt schnell dem
pflege bonus gebraucht und nicht so wie
beim letzten mal das dann doch viele
leer aus gehen aber natürlich ist reicht
nicht ein einmaliger bonus oder eine
einmalige prämie das ist nicht
nachhaltig wir müssen grundsätzlich war
es verändern an der bezahlung von
pflegekräften und wir brauchen personal
mindeststandards und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen damit arbeit in der
pflege nicht krank macht aber an der
stelle verstehe ich es nicht an anderen
stellen in dieser pandemie saßen die
milliarden so locker wenn es um andere
vorhaben ging dass ich der meinung wenn
man hätte das jetzt den pflegekräften
auch dieses jahr auszahlen müssen und
dieses jahr auf den weg bringen müssen
und das nicht auf die lange bank dann
hätte es ja vielleicht koppeln können
dass die die sich jetzt irgendwie müssen
im gesundheitsamt dann auch den geld das
geld bekommen wäre das nur sinnvolle
die pflege also die impfpflicht für die
pflegekräfte ist jetzt auf dem weg
gebracht der bonus oder ins nächste jahr
verschoben und das selbst doch ein
zeichen und das finde ich ein sehr
ungünstiges zeichen deswegen hatten wir
das beantragt das anders
wichtig ist dass dass es mehr geld gibt
für die die bei ihnen arbeiten ist das
ein punkt wo man sagt ja das macht den
beruf wirklich attraktive
absolut ist das ein ganz wichtiger
bestandteil das seien ganz klar das ist
eine komponente und viel viel wichtiger
wird es sein die arbeitsbedingung dass
er für böhme auch gesagt ich bin ja froh
dass vor vastic von der fdp jetzt auf
die schulter alten der regierung zurück
greift dann will ich auch vastic und
ihre koalitionspartner hier jetzt mal
wirklich war nachhaltig was zu machen
und nicht zu sagen auch die korona
pandemie denkt uns wieder ab davon das
haben wir jetzt zwei jahre lang nein es
sind versäumnisse in der pflege nicht
die letzten zwei jahre das ist ein
ergebnis von zehn 15 jahren nicht sagen
ich bin wirklich mittlerweile auch weiß
und grau ich bin seit 30 jahren dabei
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich als arzt
hat mich immer manchmal geschäft dafür
wie man mit der pflege umgegangen ist
und wie wenig man das berücksichtigt hat
und wie man es zugelassen hat und das
gehe ich mal ganz in richtung der fdp
dass die privatisierung des
gesundheitssystems in den letzten zehn
jahren dazu geführt hat dass gerade die
privaten krankenhäuser an der pflege sie
gespart haben um ihre erlös maximieren
voranzutreiben und da gebe ich frau
vilma das recht hier muss dringend in
dieser legislatur brill eine
grundlegende reform des
gesundheitssystems her damit die pflege
nachhaltig verbessert wird geld ist das
eine aber anerkennung und auch die
kompetenz das ist das entscheidende das
müssen sie bekommen dann müssen wir
ärzten und ernst auch mitwirken dass
vier nachhaltigkeit entwickelt und wer
endlich eine auf augenhöhe partnerinnen
partner haben die die menschen versorgen
das ist daseinsvorsorge und das gehört
wirklich an die oberste priorität für
die zukunft unseres landes also da
würden sie sagen dass sie sozusagen die
die das stück das streben nach gewinn
nach profit das gehört nicht ins
krankenhaus verstehe ich dieser sie da
richtig da sehen sie eine falsche
entwicklung auch
weil weil sie direkt angesprochen sind
von der fdp das war ja schon man pumpe
man sagt man will mehr privatisieren
sehen sie jetzt im nachhinein dass das
eine falsche entwicklung
das würde ich so nicht sagen sie müssen
sehen dass gerade bei den investitionen
die länder oft nicht agiert haben nicht
getätigt haben und dann
konnte man auch auf private
investitionen nicht verzichten aber ich
möchte noch einen ganz anderen punkt
aufgreifen den herr professor janssens
gesagt hat dass es das stichwort
augenhöhe ich freue mich sehr das
stichwort von einem mediziner zu hören
und das ist etwas was was wir als fdp
mit einem entsprechenden antrag im
bundestag eingebracht haben dass wir
gerade die pflegeausbildung besonders
stärken wollen die mehr akademisierung
in der pflege vorantreiben wollen die
pflegewissenschaftliche die forschung
vorantreiben wollen gemeinsam mit den
ländern nicht nur
damit wir zum beispiel auch genügend
pflegepädagogik und pädagogen haben die
unterrichten können allein daran mangelt
es ja schon dass wir also sehr auf die
ausbildung achten um eine augenhöhe
hinzubekommen im koalitionsvertrag haben
wir das berufsbild der community health
ich muss mich leider englisch ausdrücken
das ist wirklich meine schwester gab es
ja aber es ist eine sehr qualifizierte
pflegekraft die eben durchaus auch
ärztliche tätigkeiten übernehmen kann
derweil sie entsprechend qualifiziert
ist die uns im ländlichen raum
voranbringen wird all das gehört zu den
vorhaben dieser regierung und da ist
auch die fdp mit dabei okay aber
trotzdem die frage an die ausbildung das
war ja auch mehr viel gesagt ist wichtig
frau böhmer frau böhmer ich habe es
einmal gelesen da haben sie gesagt ich
will einmal einen dienst machen indem
ich so arbeiten kann wie es in meiner
ausbildung gelernt habe ich will möchte
endlich meinen patienten gerecht werden
also wenn sie das jetzt hören von frau
westig dass die ausbildung so wichtig
ist dann kommt ja dann doch letztendlich
das was man gelernt hat betrifft dann
auf die realität im krankenhaus und
passt da nicht ganz zusammen oder
ja genau also man lernt halt in der
ausbildung dass man zb 45 minuten zeit
hat für einen patienten mit voll flieger
also den komplett zu waschen und zu
versorgen und das geht natürlich in der
praxis überhaupt gar nicht wenn da eine
pflegekraft auch 13 patienten kommt dann
würde ich das ja gar nicht schaffen dann
ist ja fast mein ganzer tag vorbei
und ja natürlich ist die ausbildung
wichtig akademisierung
wäre vielleicht auch ein punkt aber ich
glaube wichtiger ist es jetzt gerade so
viel nachwuchs wie möglich einzuholen
und man hat ja leider auch die
ausbildung generalisiert ich krieg da
auch immer viel rückmeldung dass es
eigentlich
qualitativ eher nicht so gut ist leider
dass man halt eben
die altenpflege und krankenpflege als
einen pflegeberuf im gemeinsamen jetzt
als ausbildungsberuf hat
ja genau dadurch ist halt viel
durcheinander auch fachlich also so
bekomme ich das mit man eine kollegin
meinte zu mir man versucht irgendwie
alles neu zu erfinden und ja irgendwie
ist es ja glaube ich so dass man zwei
jahre alles lernt und dann denen das
letzte jahr sich sozusagen für eine
fachrichtung entscheidet also will ich
in die altenpflege oder will ich in die
krankenpflege und ich glaube dass es
auch so sein wird dass weniger leute
sich für die altenpflege leider
entscheiden werden und ich denke dass da
der personalmangel sich dann so
automatisch noch verschärfen wird frau
wisse was denken sie wie kann man diesen
beruf attraktiv machen dass mehr
menschen wieder diesen beruf ergreifen
da im moment kann man sich ja wohl schon
dass viele sich davor scheuen ja das
problem ist ja auch dass viele die
ausbildung abbrechen also ich war in
berlin unterwegs bei den beschäftigten
in der berliner krankenhaus bewegung die
auch gestreikt haben für gute
arbeitsbedingungen und da haben wir die
kolleginnen kollegen erzählt das hat zum
teil die hälfte eines
ausbildungsjahrgangs abbrechen weil
einfach der beruf so unattraktiv ist und
deswegen ganz klar gute bezahlung aber
eben vor allem auch gute
arbeitsbedingungen wenn immer mehr
pflegekräfte auch ihre arbeitszeit
reduzieren weil sie sagen in vollzeit
schaffe ich das überhaupt nicht das
macht nicht krank und ich finde ganz
wichtig wirklich darauf hinzuweisen das
ist ein dieser pflegenotstand ist älter
hat die korona pandemie der ist jetzt
während der korona pandemie besonders
deutlich zutage getreten aber die
pflegekräfte rufen doch schon seit
jahren um hilfe und ich bin völlig bei
frau böhmer dass wir dafür nicht einfach
nur an der einen oder anderen stelle mal
eine prämie einen bonus wir müssen
wirklich das gesundheitssystem komplett
umbauen und das muss klar unter dem
motto stehen menschen vor profite war
das wisst ja jede menge geld im
gesundheitssystem vestia wir brauchen
die privaten investitionen mehrwert
schaffen das nicht das problem ist ja
gerade dass durch die privatisierung in
lohn viel geld abgezogen wird aus dem
gesundheitssystem weil das ja richtig
gesagt worden man kann in diesem land
mit pflege richtig viel geld verdienen
vorausgesetzt man ist eine pflegekraft
aber immer ein privater
krankenhauskonzerns oder ein privater
pflege konzern dann kann man damit ja
wirklich richtig ruhe dreistellige
millionengewinne machen und das ist doch
geld was aus einem öffentlichen
gesundheitssystem abgezogen wird und was
daneben pflegt was daneben fehlt und das
geht auf kosten der beschäftigten und
auf kosten auf kosten der patientinnen
und patienten deswegen wir müssen die
privatisierung des gesundheitssystems
stoppen wir müssen krankenhäuser
rekommunalisieren und wir müssen weg von
den fallpauschalen diese ökonomisierung
des gesundheitssystems die muss aufhören
und da finde ich muss man ansetzen wenn
man über gute arbeit spricht das gilt
für die krankenhäuser das gilt für die
pflegeheime und auch für den bereich der
ambulanten pflege der oft vergessen wird
und gerade sind da die beschäftigten
auch in der korona krise möglich im
stich gelassen worden
wie würden sie es schafft man das ohne
private investitionen schaffen man das
wenn man so wie frau wissler das sagt
rekommunalisieren ist dann da genug geld
oder wie müsste man es angehen
ich richtig jetzt mal mein appell an die
beiden spitzenpolitiker die bei innern
tisch sitzen es ist doch vollkommen klar
die gesundheit um die es geht um muss er
bevölkerung das ist doch daseinsfürsorge
schauen sie sich doch die
bevölkerungsentwicklung der letzten
jahrzehnte
wir haben doch eine veränderung zu einer
nacht völlig ich sage das aber
überspitzt überalterten bevölkerung die
von unten her kaum noch menschen hat die
nachkommen die sie versorgen das sind
doch daten die sind längst bekannt und
wenn wir über privatisierung reden
nochmals die gesellschaft da ist die
politik auf für verantwortet den
menschen das zu sagen die gesellschaft
will doch selber dafür sorge tragen dass
sie eine gute versorgung hat sowohl dem
krankenhaus im ambulanten system wie
später auch in dem pflegeheim und das
kann man doch wirklich nicht an börsen
unter notierten unternehmen überlassen
das am ende geld aus der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung abziehen um
aktionäre zu bedienen das hat mit freier
marktwirtschaft nichts zu tun die haben
wird sich und daseinsvorsorge das wäre
ungefähr so als wenn die feuerwehr und
die polizei geld verdienen müsste und
das würde dann nachher noch an
irgendwelche dritt leute abgeführt da
bitte ich darum dass die politik das
erkennt und das ist eine große last und
frau wyss hat das zu recht gesagt dass
die ag finanzierte sonntags den muss
grundlegend reformiert werden wir
hecheln hier den punkten hinterher
die krankheit sagt können gar nicht
anders die länder haben sich völlig aus
der verantwortung heraus gezogen da ist
auch ihre partei
frau lästig doch mittlerweile auch kann
daran beteiligt sein dass das erkannt
wird dass die länder hat die gelder in
die krankenhäuser eingeben und die
krankenhäuser nicht unnötige operationen
machen müssen damit sie in der lage sind
ihren mitarbeiter oder investitionen zu
tätigen damit die versorgung weiter
läuft das ist ein ganz wichtiger appell
frau westig zusammen würde ich dir gerne
dürfen sie gerne darauf reagieren wie
sehr sie nehmen sie sich diesen appell
zu herzen ich nehme mir den appell zu
herzen wir müssen
wir brauchen grundlegende reformen aber
sie werden von mir jetzt nicht hören
dass ich hier auf das pferd aufspringen
einer totalen rekommunalisierung dar
warum nicht erklären sie uns herum nähe
weil wir haben fehlanreize im system und
gerade im bereich der die ags gibt es
viele fehlanreize
aber wir arbeiten daran da muss ich
sogar die vorgängerregierung einmal
loben sie hat die pflege rausgenommen
aus den dia und wir haben das sind die
fallpauschalen über die krankenhaus
abgerechnet wird und wir entwickeln das
weiter im rahmen der ampel regierung
dass wir sagen auch was die geburtshilfe
angeht was die pädiatrie angeht die
kinderheilkunde das wollen wir auch raus
nehmen um eben entsprechende fehlanreize
rauszunehmen von daher denke ich wir
können uns da schon irgendwo treffen wir
haben das problem erkannt
es gibt wie wir müssen aber auch so
ehrlich sein dass wir nicht jedes
krankenhaus werden erhalten können wir
gebrauchen denn ich jetzt in der
controller zeit gemerkt dass wir gerade
wir brauchen eine bedarfsgerechte
versorgung aber wir haben trotz allem
gibt es auch bei uns an der einen oder
anderen stelle das da zitiere ich jetzt
karl lauterbach
überversorgung und da müssen wir
hinkommen dass wir die
versorgung so bedarfsgerecht ausrichten
dass sie zum zum patientenwohl
ausgerichtet wird und frau wissler wie
empfinden sie das die schütteln mit dem
kopf jedes verständnis dafür wie man in
der derzeitigen situation und bei dem
pflegenotstand und bei der situation die
wir haben jetzt ernsthaft über
überversorgung und über die schließung
von krankenhäusern sprechen kann weil
ich meine wir haben doch gesehen dass
eben dadurch dass wenn krankenhäuser
geschlossen der natürlich auch wege
weiter werden das teilweise
geburtsstationen kreißsäle überhaupt
nicht mehr in der gut erreichbarer nähe
sind also jetzt müssen wir doch und
dritte also das grundproblem ist auch
und davon haben sie sich immer noch
nicht verabschiedet das
gesundheitsversorgung dass krankenhäuser
dürfen doch nicht etwas sein mit denen
private geld verdienen und weil dann
natürlich das dazu führt dass man
versucht kosten zu sparen beim personal
dass man versucht eben die sogenannten
patienten fernen tätigkeiten was ich
auch für falsch halte outsourcen und
günstiger zu vergeben wir haben es noch
erlebt bei den reinigungsdiensten zum
beispiel in den krankenhäusern dass
immer größere flächen gereinigt werden
müssen und ich finde wir müssen doch aus
dieser krise jetzt die lehre ziehen dass
wir eine gute versorgung brauchen dass
wir mehr pflegekräfte brauchen und dass
die krankenhäuser gut ausgestattet
werden müssen und dass gerade durch die
schließung von krankenhäusern sind
gerade die häuser der maximalversorgung
die unikliniken zum beispiel die sind
besonders stark davon betroffen weil die
an die patienten dann natürlich alle
noch zusätzlich dorthin kommen und diese
entwicklung haben wir doch und das sehen
wir doch zum teil auch in den
notaufnahmen ok klares wort zu sagen ich
kurz sagen herr jansen und seine frau
bin ja jansons bitte ich geh befestigt
wirklich an einem punkt recht und ich
würde auch sagen wir dürfen durchaus
auch selbst in der korona panne mir das
wort überversorgung in dem unternehmen
müssen es ist sogar auch weil wir
tatsächlich jetzt spürt dass wir an
vielen ecken tatsächlich
notfallversorgung gar nicht mehr gewährt
das bekommt von allen auch von patienten
ohne co mit 19 ist ein ganz wichtiges
problem und ich denke schon dass unser
land auf ein weg gebracht werden muss
und das ist die aufgabe hier ihrer ihrer
kunst ihrer politikerinnen und politiker
endlich mal mit den menschen vernünftig
darüber zu reden was denn gewollt ist
und was nicht gewollt ist und ich glaube
schon dass man gute strukturen schaffen
kann in deutschland wenn man es den
menschen hätten dafür werden sie jahre
brauchen sie müssen das den menschen
erklären dass sie vielleicht für die
eine oder andere leistung
hochqualifiziert 100 km/h muss trotzdem
ihre grundversorgung ihre gesamt
versorgung vor ort erhalten bleibt das
ist die gestaltung die jetzt die
gesundheitspolitik land auf stadt
ergreifen muss und deshalb denke ich
schon und jedes und integrations
qualität wir müssen zurück zu einer
patient zentrierten guten integrations
qualität und nicht die darauf beruht
dass wir gelder einsammeln müssen zur
leistungen die vielleicht in eine
überversorgung mit vor will man sie
wollten auch zu organe was zu sagen
ja also wenn ich jetzt gerade so an
meiner entbindung zurückdenke dann habe
ich vor der entbindung jeden tag
gezittert dass wenn es jetzt losgeht
dass zum beispiel
der kreißsaal in dem krankenhaus wo ich
entbinden wollte voll ist und da hätte
ich zum beispiel angst gehabt dass ich
jetzt mehrere kilometer weit fahren muss
nur um irgendwo einbinden zu können also
ich finde dass es kontraproduktiv wenn
wir jetzt mehrere krankenhäuser
schließen würden auch für die ältere
bevölkerung
die halten nicht ziemlich weit fahren
können denn irgendwie mal notfall ist
oder so also ich denke dass das
kontraproduktiv ok klang entscheidende
frage ist ja wonach orientieren wir uns
bei der krankenhausplanung und
orientieren wir uns an der daran dass
man kosten sparen will und dass man
einsparungen haben will orientieren wir
uns daran oder orientieren wir uns daran
was ist das beste für die patienten und
patienten und in den letzten jahren
immer wenn ich steh rede von war
krankenhäuser zu schließen ging es doch
nicht darum die gesundheitliche
versorgung zu verbessern sondern es ging
immer um den aspekt der kosteneinsparung
und das ist das problem im
gesundheitssystem dass wir einfach die
maxime nicht stimmen und dass diese
ökonomisierung des gesundheitssystems
das ist das grundproblem und natürlich
kann man auch sagen krankenhäuser
konzentrieren sich dass eine
konzentriert sich mehr auf das oder das
andere mehr auf das aber es muss aus der
sicht von wohle des patienten und
patienten und der beschäftigten heraus
geplant werden und nicht eben immer nur
unter dem aspekt der kostenreduktion
aber es ist natürlich auch schwierig
wenn man sich über ein neues
gesundheitssystem oder eine aufstellung
neuaufstellung überlegt plant man dass
das die dass es so ist dass man in einer
pandemie damit gut fährt weil wir hoffen
hier alle dass wir die pandemie kein
dauerzustand ist das ist ja auch dann
ganz schwer also zu höre ich möchte aber
jetzt noch mal sagen dass wenn sie den
koalitionsvertrag lesen sehr wohl
erkennen dass wir eine bedarfsgerechte
versorgung wollen und dass wir sind
gerade die situation die frau böhme
schilderte ich komme aus dem
rhein-sieg-kreis da sind in der kürzeren
vergangenheit drei
geburtsstationen geschlossen worden
zuletzt in meine heimatstadt und ich
kann diese ängste absolut verstehen wir
brauchen eine wohnortnahe
geburtshilfe das steht in unserem
koalitionsvertrag drin und das wollen
wir sichern dafür darauf haben wir uns
verständigt schauen wir noch mal ein
bisschen auf die aktuelle entwicklung
corona es gibt einen neuen
gesundheitsminister es gibt einen
krisenstab jetzt der heute die arbeit
aufgenommen hat die gesundheitsminister
haben getagt da ging es darum dass die
booster die leute die gepustet sind dann
bald kein test mehr machen müssen frau
wissler wie viel vertrauen haben sie in
den neuen gesundheitsminister jetzt bei
der korona bekämpfung
also ich muss sagen dass die
ampel in den letzten wochen und wo es ja
das parlament ja auch getagt hat viel zu
viel zeit verstreichen lassen also das
ist meine kritik natürlich an der großen
koalition die bis letzte woche im amt
war aber jetzt auch an der ampel dass
man wirklich noch vor zwei monaten über
freedom day und anderes gesprochen hat
gerade die fdp und damit ja auch den
menschen ein gefühl der sicherheit
vermittelt hat was überhaupt nicht
angebracht war und die warnungen der
expertinnen und experten hören wir doch
schon seit dem sommer und wo mir völlig
das verständnis fehlt ist wie man diese
poster kampagne organisiert hat also
dann schafft man im oktober die
kostenfreien tests ab wann schließt die
impfzentren und jetzt haben wir die
situation dass leute der fünf sechs
sieben stunden in der kälte stehen für
die booster impfung an zu stehen das hat
man noch gewusst also wir wussten doch
dass die auffrischungsimpfung kommen
muss wir wussten doch dass die
kinderimpfungen ende des jahres kommen
also die schließung der jüngsten halte
ich für ein riesiges problem und auch
das jetzt bei der booster kampagne
überhaupt nicht mehr priorisiert wurde
jetzt ist nämlich das problem dass die
30-jährigen bewusster werden das ist ja
auch super das gar nicht gehen auch aber
der 85 jährige hat ja nächstes jahr mehr
einen termin beim hausarzt und dass man
nicht gesagt hat wie menschen die auch
als erstes geimpft wurden nämlich die
pflegekräfte die hochbetagten dass die
jetzt nicht priorisiert gepustet werden
sondern so ein bisschen so ein
windhundrennen an vielen orten ist also
in hessen erlebe ich das zumindest sehr
stark so wär halt eben stundenlang
anstehen kann kriegt die impfung und wir
nicht dann eben nicht das halte ich für
ein riesiges problem und das ist
wirklich ein versagen der politik und
gleichzeitig hat man ja sehr schnell die
impfpflicht für personal im
gesundheitswesen beschlossen herr
janssen wie ist das bei ihren ihren
kolleginnen und kollegen angekommen das
ist diese eben pflicht jetzt dann
letztendlich ab dem 15 märz 2022 geben
soll
ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht gut ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir haben sehr
stark dafür plädiert angesichts der
situation sie sich entwickelt hat dass
ich wählen wenn man sich politisch dafür
entscheide ist eine politische
entscheidung dann bitte schön für alle
es ist auch an dieser stelle das muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen viele meiner
mitarbeiter innen aus den pflegeberuf
die auch games sind haben dafür
überhaupt kein verständnis mehr garten
haben gesagt ja ich war handel den
ganzen tag hier unsere erste patientin
person gehen soll meine kollegin unter
umständen sogar wenn das jetzt kommt
aussortiert werden die sich darum
kümmert sich tag fest ich testen lässt
und ich spanier schwerstkranke patienten
die unbeirrt sind also das verständnis
war wenig da und wir haben ganz klar
dafür plädiert dass wenn man sich dafür
entscheidet aus der in der lage der
epidemie heraus dann für alle noch viel
schlimmer ist die kommunikation der
letzten wochen und monate da hat frau
wisse ja schon darauf hingewiesen aber
ich glaube das sollte man hinter sich
lassen aber jetzt sollte es doch soweit
sein dass wir jetzt mit einem neuen
bundesgesundheitsminister haben und wir
haben eigentlich ein krisenstab sondern
ein expertenstab und das begrüßen wird
total und wollen hoffen dass die länder
jetzt endlich mal danach richten und
sich nicht alle fünf minuten etwas neues
ausdenken noch das waren wenn ich heute
morgen wach da verkündet die
landesregierung booster impfung schon
nach vier wochen wer hat das denn
gefunden warum wartet man nicht und
wartet ab was die experten aber sagt ich
plädiere dringend dafür endlich von
diesem weg abzuweichen dauern die leute
mit neuen maßnahmen zu verstören uns
experten übrigens auch ich verstehe es
selbst als mediziner kaum noch was auf
der ebene da in den letzten wochen und
monate geschehen ist und vielleicht noch
mal zur klarstellung ich hab das eben
vielleicht falsch außer es gibt den
experten
in grund von vielen wissenschaftlern
wissen und es gibt einen krisenstab an
der der sozusagen die sachen organisiert
sondern dass wir das noch mal sortieren
es gibt sozusagen beides aber noch mal
ganz kurz die nachfrage haben sie denn
viele ungeimpfte noch im personal- und
wir haben befürchten sie jetzt dass die
menschen verlieren oder werden neben
pflicht für die gibt
ich kann ihnen ganz klar sagen wir haben
nicht geschafft haben anfang 40 prozent
mitarbeiter ende gehabt die tatsächlich
sehr skeptisch waren also november vor
einem jahr wie wir kurz vor der in
pfungstadt wir haben es durch lokale
kampagnen aufklärungsgespräche geschafft
die quote auf 7 90 prozent zu erheben
woanders im pflegeheim ist das
tatsächlich ein bisschen anders aber in
der tat habe ich ein zweiter mitarbeiter
die jetzt tatsächlich verstehen dass sie
dann eventuell im märz dann nicht mehr
weiterarbeiten können und das ist auf
der einen seite wir versuchen die
gespräche zu führen auf der anderen
seite ist es für uns ein verlust weil
sind wertvolle mitarbeiter den super job
machen und ich möchte dass ich auch
nicht bewerten ich zeige übrigens auch
nicht mit dem finger auf diese leute
sondern versucht sie jeden tag auf soll
zu verstehen und zu überzeugen das
gelingt mir leider gottes nicht aber so
ist es ja landauf landab über also das
heißt dieses diese division der menschen
das ist das was mir den letzten monaten
auch am meisten gestört hat dass wir so
gegenseitig mit den fingern auf andere
zeigen probleme wie sehen sie das dass
das personal im gesundheitswesen das ist
für die jetzt eine impfpflicht gilt aber
noch keine generelle impfpflicht
also ich sehe das eigentlich genau so
und ich habe auch die rückmeldung von
meinen kollegen auch so von geimpften
und ungeimpften personal das sie
ziemlich sauer sind das die pflicht halt
nur für uns gilt bzw für leute die in
gesundheitseinrichtungen arbeiten und
ich habe auch gesehen wie herr
lauterbach und bundestag gesagt hat dass
es nicht akzeptabel ist dass menschen
sterben weil ungeimpfte personal dort
gearbeitet hat und dafür hätte ich gern
beweise wie er auf so was kommt und es
ist doch so dass die menschen in den
gesundheitswesen sterben weil man
jahrelang die situation einfach
ignoriert hat
bei personalmangel besteht ich mein
gehirn genug betten können die aber
nicht bedienen weil halt einfach nicht
genug personal da ist und wir wurden
verheizt am anfang der pandemie wir
hatten nicht genug schutzausrüstung weil
die politik das nicht geschafft hat
material zu beschaffen wir sollten
positiv arbeiten und jetzt auf einmal
ist hier ein kleiner teil von personen
irgendwie schuld dass menschen sterben
also ich weiß nicht ich finde das alles
sehr ungerecht und ich musste herr
janssen auch zustimmen ich mag auch
dieses gegenseitige
auf also aufeinander der schuld zuweisen
und auf mit dem finger aufeinander
zeigen mag ich nicht wir müssten alle
zusammenarbeiten an hat das ist ja in
einer pandemie sollten dann wirklich
alle zusammen halten sonst drehen wir
uns einfach auch die ganze zeit im kreis
frau wisse sie haben sich enthalten bei
der abstimmung für das personal sind
aber grundsätzlich eigentlich schon für
eine impfpflicht für alle oder hab sie
da falsch verstanden ja wir haben uns
enthalten aus unterschiedlichen gründen
also zum beispiel auch weil eben der
pflege bonus nicht teil das gesetzpaket
war es aber zum beispiel auch weil wir
es auch für ein schwieriges signal
halten weil das ist ja nun nicht so dass
die impfquote unterbeschäftigten im
gesundheitsbereich jetzt niedriger wäre
als in der gesamtbevölkerung sondern
ganz im gegenteil
und wir sehen schon dass da ein
schwieriges signal gesetzt wird wenn man
sagt den leuten die erzieher seit
22 monaten ja menschenleben retten dass
man damit in der kommunikation ja sagt
ihr lasst euch nicht impfen und ihr seid
damit irgendwie pandemie treiber und das
fanden wir schwierig in der aussage
grundsätzlich sind wir der meinung dass
wir viel mehr aufklärung brauchen wir
brauchen mobile teams und wir müssen die
fragen der menschen beantworten das gibt
ja auch gerade wenn man sich den
unterschied anschaut zwischen den
europäischen staaten aber auch zwischen
den bundesländern also bremen zum
beispiel was wirklich nur die höchste im
pfote hat deutschlandweit
haben wir gefragt ist eine linke
gesundheitssenatorin hier haben wir
eingeladen gefragt was habt ihr gemacht
und die haben gesagt ja wir sind ich
heute steht aber auch gut da mit dem
liberalen gesundheitsminister
das ist das ist sehr gut das freut mich
auch also ich meine das ist ja kein
gegeneinander sondern es geht doch genau
darum zu lernen was ist gut was was ist
gut gemacht worden und da hat man
wirklich in die stadtteile reingegangen
mann ist in die vereine gegangen man hat
wirklich auch mit sozialarbeit und mit
aufklärung und mit fragen beantworten
eben versucht die menschen zu erreichen
und deswegen ich finde ja man muss auch
über die allgemeine impfpflicht
diskutieren aber die wird uns ja jetzt
auch nicht in dieser vierten welle
helfen die wird uns ja nicht kurzfristig
helfen in den nächsten drei vier fünf
sondern sie wird langfristig helfen und
ich glaube den menschen die jetzt gerade
versuchen verzweifelt den hausarzt
termin zu bekommen wo wir gerade heute
erfahren haben dass genug impfstoff von
boostern da ist und auch euren menschen
die jetzt erstmalig sich impfen lassen
wollen und einfach ewig anstehen müssen
ich glaube die für sie ein bisschen
verkehr hat man jetzt von der
impfpflicht die rede ist die brauchen
erstmal einen fragebogen wir haben heute
die lage kommen das hat der
gesundheitsminister heute auch gesagt
das ist nach seiner information
wahrscheinlich nicht genug impfstoff
geben wird im ersten quartal frau wer
sich wie wird diese neue ampelkoalition
damit umgehen und weil das wird ja
wieder zu einer belastung bei unserem
thema zu bleiben und der belastung auch
in den kliniken führen ja das halte ich
für ein großes problem dass es jetzt
plötzlich nicht genug impfstoff gibt das
offensichtlich nicht genug impfstoff
bestellt worden ist ich hatte eigentlich
gedacht dass wir diese zeiten hinter uns
gelassen haben aber ich betone noch mal
dass ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig
wir übernehmen gerade verantwortung und
uns werden jetzt dinge vorgeworfen vom
september oktober ich möchte mir nicht
vorstellen wenn olaf scholz oder karl
lauterbach im oktober gesagt hätten
ergreifen wir hier mal härtere corona
maßen haben weil einfach die situation
noch nicht so war da bitte ich um
verständnis das ist schwierig wir müssen
das haben sie auch gesagt die
bevölkerung mitnehmen ich halte es aber
ich bin da ganz bei ihnen ich halte es
aber für schwierig über eine impf
allgemeine impfpflicht zu diskutieren
solange im angebote nicht leer stehen
sondern eben lange schlangen dort
herrschen da müssen wir erst noch unsere
hausaufgaben machen alle die sich impfen
lassen wollen müssen schnellstmöglich
geimpft werden und ich hoffe dass wir da
jetzt schnell nachschub bekommen beim
impfstoff damit wir wirklich alle die
das möchten auch bedienen können sie
haben jetzt ja
ist es nicht so im transparent das sie
als noch ob es überhaupt nicht wussten
oder wissen wieviel impfstoffe da sind
das ist doch ein thema was uns seit
monaten bewegt das musste doch darf
jedoch nicht entgangen sein sie können
doch anfragen an den
bundesgesundheitsminister stellen also
mich wundert das ist gar nicht dass ich
höre und ich schreibe mir nicht
verwundert die augen dass wir mal wieder
nicht genügend impfstoff haben da gebe
ich ihnen vollkommen recht und der
impfstoff brown sogar eine impfpflicht
also wenn sie nicht zu den fahren
brauchen sie auch keine zu verpflichten
aber hier und da gebe ich ihnen muss ich
ihnen auch sagen die gesamten letzten
sechs monate sind alle parteien mit
bundestagswahlkampfs beschäftigt gewesen
das thema corona spielte keine rolle
keiner von ihnen wollte unangenehme
ansagen machen und in der periode
zwischen den beiden regierungen ist gar
nichts passiert gut das lassen wir jetzt
mal hinter uns aber deshalb umso
wichtiger dass sie auch mal sagen ja da
haben wir fehler gemacht auch als
oppositionspartei und das werden wir
jetzt als
regierungspartei in die hand nehmen und
verbessern das ist doch ganz wichtig
frau becker und dann darauf immer
absolut aber ich möchte auch betonen
dass wir immer gesagt haben der im turbo
ist uns nicht genug gezündet worden wir
brauchen mehr niedrigschwellige angebote
wir haben im april gesagt wir möchten
impfen auf dem supermarktparkplatz da
wurden wir verlacht nach dem motto ihr
seid auch der meinung der markt regelt
alles so ist es gelaufen wir sind immer
dafür gewesen für diese
niedrigschwelligen beratungen und wir
haben immer auch mit sorge gesehen dass
die impfquote
nicht eine zahl erreicht hat die
wünschenswert wäre und man sieht man ja
immer noch keine großen sprüche auf den
supermarkt parkplätzen sondern man
diskutiert über die impfpflicht für alle
also das stimmt doch irgendwie dann auf
doch es gibt jetzt also ich denke das
kann man schon sagen dass es durch die
vierte welle schon ein das angebot
erweitert worden ist dass sie sollte
stehen
ja ich kenne ich auch aber frau böhmer
sie wollten auch noch sich dazu melden
ja ich wollte sagen ich finde es
schwierig man will nicht über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht reden und
beschließt dann aber eine irgendwie
wollen auch lieber nur allgemeine
impfung geben wo darf ich darf ja das
müsste aber ich meine jetzt jetzt hat
man erstmal jetzt hat man erst mal eine
impfpflicht für die pflegekräfte
beschlossen obwohl sowieso der größte
teil geimpft ist und ich meine man
entscheidet immer über unsere köpfe
hinweg man fragt die pflege das ist die
ganze pandemie schon so immer meint man
alles für uns entscheiden zu müssen oder
besser zu wissen man fragt uns nicht mal
wie es geht man fragt immer mobil ist
gerade die lage auf den
intensivstationen und es ist immer das
gleiche und man lernt einfach nichts
dazu und wir können uns verheizt und wir
fühlen uns übergangen und ich glaube der
größte teil hat wirklich langsam die
schnauze gestrichen voll und es werden
einige gehen und das wird
kontraproduktiv sein und irgendwann
werden wir uns alle um gucken wenn
einfach keiner mehr am bett steht
da bin ich sehr bei ihnen dass man die
pflege viel zu wenig fragt und ich reibe
mir auch die augen dass in dem jetzt neu
geschaffenen expertengremium erneut die
pflege nicht vertreten ist also da
möchte ich es sind jetzt neun zehn
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
da denke ich 20 ist eine gute zahl der
gehört schnellstmöglich nachgebessert
dass die pflege da reinkommt ich hab das
schon kritisiert zu beginn der pandemie
als der korona krisenstab eingerichtet
wurde und wir haben gesehen wir haben
beide das beweisen sie in hull die augen
reiben sondern sie müssen das ihrem
ehrentag unter die nase der rest werde
ich auch machen ich werde mich dafür
verwenden dass die da noch nachgebessert
wird und die pflege auch sitz in diesem
expertengremium bekommt denn das ist
ausgesprochen wichtig okay die bayern
der bayerische ministerpräsident möchte
eine verdoppelung des gehalts der
gehälter der intensivpflege herr jansen
hat er jetzt gefordert ist das denn ist
das was wo sie sagen okay aber super
wenn man das funktioniert dann werden
sich bei mir die leute irgendwie wenn
die schlange stehen
nochmals sehr geehrter lieber
ministerpräsident söder die
intensivpflege das ist wirklich ein ganz
wichtiger bestandteil unserer versorgung
in den krankenhäusern aber ich muss
jetzt an der stelle sagen ich halte
davon überhaupt nichts hier also eine
klassengesellschaft aufzumachen mir ist
jeder jede pflegekraft wege
pflegehilfskraft die auch auf einer
normalstation genauso lieb genauso
wichtig sie mit empathie an die
patienten angeht also das muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen das ist das völlig falsch
lag nach der bitte frau böhmer mit
sicherheit recht geben also wir dürfen
hier nicht jetzt so eine eine stufen
gesellschaft in der innerhalb der pflege
aufbauen dass das dann die besten wenn
die sind alle fantastisch und ich sag
das wirklich mit herzblut ich bin immer
noch dankbar für meine erste nächte als
assistenzarzt dass ich mit pflegekräften
umgeben war die mir geholfen haben das
habe ich den noch nie vergessen deshalb
kämpfe ich seit jahren dafür auch mit
herzblut dafür dass hier eine wirkliche
nicht wiedersehen singulär irgendwo auf
einem blick besondere gesamte
berufsstand bisschen die altenpflege
endlich das bekommt und zwar geld ist
das eine aber auch die anerkennung und
ihren berufsstand so auszugestalten dass
ist jetzt aufgabe der politik dass das
ein zukunftsträchtiger boss ist ich
möchte auch noch später jemanden haben
der mich versorgt und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich da jemanden an meiner
seite haben mit sehr so liebevoll mit
mir umgeht wie ich das jetzt im
augenblick tangos erlebe heute bei der
besitzer wenn die schwestern am bett der
patienten stehen ja frau böhmer sie sind
jetzt schon gesagt sie sind jetzt gerade
auch in elternzeit und werden sich ja
dann überlegen wann sie wieder
zurückkehren in ihren beruf mörsen punkt
wo sie sagen ja der beruf ist ich mag
den so gerne der es mir so wichtig ich
gehe gerne zurück
ja also ich liebe meinen beruf und ich
würde super gerne wieder zurückgehen und
ich werde wahrscheinlich auch erstmal
lernen also wieder zurückgehen die frage
ist nur wie lange ich wirklich in den
beruf beiden sinne also wenn sich jetzt
nicht sichtbar irgendetwas ändert dann
weiß ich auch nicht wie lange ich das
noch mache weil also auch wenn man den
beruf liebt aber man muss sich halt auch
nicht die ganze zeit auf opfern also
irgendwann muss man auch mal
schlussstrich ziehen vor allem wenn es
einen dann so belastet dass man zum
beispiel ja weiß ich nicht in dem donna
feld oder so das gibt es ja auch ganz
viele kollegen sagen zur zeit sie sind
so erschöpft sie können nicht mehr und
sie überlegen schon sich was anderes zu
suchen leider weil ja also aber gibt es
einfach cool sagen wird ob und wenn sie
jemanden wenn sie jemand überzeugen
möchten dass es ein guter beruf ist
welchen satz sagen sie dann
welche die saga als ja das ist ein
schöner beruf auf jeden fall ich meine
man der ist sehr abwechslungsreich
fachlich ist ziemlich hoch so wie wir
wissen ja ungemein viel über die
anatomie und wir können krankheiten
erkennen und in notfallsituationen
reagieren und erhalt das menschliche
alles so schön wenn die
arbeitsbedingungen hat auch super werden
ja okay gut dann nehmen wir das mal als
los das problem und hoffen darf die
arbeitsbedingungen sich verbessern
vielen dank herr professor die ganze
frau bislang beste und natürlich frau
böhmer und vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen ist die phoenix runde
wieder für sie da denn morgen hält
bundeskanzler olaf scholz seine
regierungserklärung im bundestag und wir
schauen dann mal abends wie das wohl so
war es dann
[Musik]